hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the horrifying game about
horrifying piranhas that wanna
horrifyingly suckle the blood out of her
also known as your meat ah my cup and up
dear balls right my still little red you
can see oh oh
cows oh is this another farm okay I want
some livestock
I'm Vincent a giass today there are a
handful but it's nice to make a
difference in someone's life
thanks penny you're cute
I would love to get to the point where
I'm good enough and I'm not nearly there
yet but I'm good enough that I could
some friends of mine and we could
actually go to like a city rent out a
theater maybe do a charity event maybe
just do it for fun so my philosophy on
life is just to go ahead and as much as
I can as many people or as many things
as possible and try to bit better than I
came into it Wade is one of my oldest
friends and I can't wait to Bob and Wade
out here so that we can all stuff
together and have a lot of fun and
hopefully live out your life and salmon
and hibernate a long time and then an
oscar-winning actor and he's lost in the
woods as a fur trapper
I can only ponder that I need to do what
bears do which is food mate someone in
the woods and then picnic baskets forest
fires I honestly don't know who it bears
a tube in the woods besides you won't
see another don't live challenge what
other guests in here so thank you and
everybody for watching and as always
with you in the next video bye bye